salut à tous cette semaine chez sport
vous emmène sur la côte ouest de la
manche pour raconter une belle histoire
celle de city club de foot du
département punir venir en aide à une
quarantaine de migrants hébergés ici
depuis un mois c'est parti
l'horizon reste bouché mais le décor a
changé
après des mois passés dans la jungle de
calais c'est dans ce centre de vacances
sur la côte ouest du cotentin qu'une
quarantaine de migrants a trouvé refuge
ils sont jeunes
presque tous afghans ils ont fui la
guerre et leur prière restent les mêmes
se faire une petite place en france ou
ailleurs en europe depuis un mois
c'est ici à saint germain sur et qu ils
se refont un moral et une santé loin de
calais et de sa jungle
lieu le regard d'un point de vue sur la
mer bien sûr que c'est bien lui le
problème
le seul problème c'est qu'on est un peu
loin sinon les gens sont vraiment
gentils j'ai pas les seuls pour arriver
en france
ces jeunes migrants ont traversé
l'europe souvent à pied et au péril de
leur vie ont demandé l'asile en
attendant des bénévoles comme laurent se
relaie pour les aider d'attendre que
leur situation sera réglée c'est quand
même compliqué emotionnellement pour eux
donc même si des petits moments et c'est
des petites choses s'aggravent
aujourd'hui dans la cour du centre
d'hébergement un entraînement de foot
est organisé pour la première fois pour
les afghans le foot est presque une
découverte en afghanistan on joue plutôt
au cricket
là bas les talibans avaient interdit le
cricket parce que c'est un sport anglais
c'était impossible
se dépenser
juste pour le plaisir la plupart de ces
gamins n'avait plus connu cette
sensation depuis des années wahid 23 ans
est l'un des rares afghans à être fans
de foot
dans son village avant l'arrivée des
talibans il était gardien de but
le foot et la france il en est dingue
depuis un soir de juillet 2006
pour sûr
tu m'as dit
à
jours
où
nous il est lui aussi
vers des mongols dans mon village il n'y
avait pas la télé mais ferme avait
emmené en ville pour regarder cette
finale de coupe du monde entre la france
et je n'avais jamais vu un match c'est
devenu ma passion
wahid a laissé en afghanistan sa femme
et ses deux enfants
le chemin pour l'europe étant trop
dangereux
en attendant d'obtenir des papiers et de
les faire venir en france
il a passé huit mois dans la jungle de
calais là bas wahid dormait seul sous
une petite tente est hantée chaque jour
de monter dans un camion
direction l'angleterre la peur et le
danger quotidien à seulement 23 ans mais
rien comparé à la vie chez lui en
afghanistan
mon village en afghanistan il y a
beaucoup de talibans
la vie y était impossible mon petit
frère de 16 ans a été jeté en prison
comme ça avec les talibans on ne peut
même pas se mettre en short on joue au
foot
cela faisait quatre ans que wahid
n'avait plus taper dans un ballon
alors comme les autres il croque un fait
dans ce petit match de foot
une partie improvisée dans la cour du
centre d'hébergement de saint germain
sur et entre les flaques une heure pour
oublier les mois de galère qu'ils
viennent de traverser
en attendant peut-être d'obtenir l'asile
en france
et de reprendre le cours de leur vie
c'est un soir particulier pour ou aïd et
adèle deux jeunes afghans
ce soir jean les emmène disputer un
entraînement de foot
un vrai avec le petit club de l'est ces
gens comme d'autres habitants s'est
mobilisée pour aider les réfugiés
hébergés dans la manche on entend un peu
de tout bois c'est vrai que il ya les
gens sont un petit peu méfiant mais bon
le fait qu'il sache il y a des gens du
local qui organise des matchs de foot
c'est une bonne exemple pour les tous
les gens de la région
wahid et adèle ne sont pas très à l'aise
un peu intimidés par leur nouvelle
équipe pour aider les migrants les
joueurs du club de l'essai ont récolté
des chaussures et des équipements le
cachet socata
ayew si vous êtes un peu stressé yahia
ouais ouais pas et ce n'est pas parce
que ça fait presque six ans que je
n'avais pas joué au foot dans un vrai
club
ils ont connu la guerre comme à la
guerre
nos parents ont connu nos arrière grands
parents ont connu ça et aujourd'hui ce
donc que qu'il soit blanc craint jaune
ondam le foot avant d'arriver en france
ou aïd 23 ans et adèle 25 ans ont connu
les bombardements et la vie sous le
régime des talibans dans leur village
jouer au foot et est inenvisageable
quelle sensation fois ça me fait quelles
sensations je me sens bien je me sens
bien en jambes ce soir là wahid peut
enfin remettre les gants pour faire ce
qu'il aime le plus être gardien de but
le 10 décembre prochain
six clubs du coin ont décidé d'organiser
un match amical face aux réfugiés
hébergés dans la manche ce n'est pas si
anodin dans le canton de laisser un
électeur sur trois a voté pour le front
national lors des dernières élections
cette opération cet événement c'est
unique en france et puis quand on voit
le débat qu'il ya autour de deux de ces
migrants de ces réfugiés je préfère
qu'on parle de réfugiés qui ont été
placés sur toute la france quand on voit
le bas le buzz qui a eu déjà autour de
calais de cette jungle
après bon voilà c'est par rapport à
notre passion qu'est le foot que ça
s'est fait à nos valeurs au partage
après avoir traversé l'europe entière
risqué leur vie en embarquant sur des
camions dans le port de calais
abdelwahed se retrouvent ici à jouer au
foot sur un petit terrain de normandie
je suis super heureux c'était génial de
jouer avec des joueurs français j'ai
adoré cette journée c'est le meilleur
moment 2 mai
l'entraînement de foot se termine pour
adèle et wahid les jeunes réfugiés
afghans
ce soir c'est le coeur un peu plus léger
qu ils retrouveront leurs centres
d'hébergement
voilà c'est sport c'est fini pour
aujourd'hui salut à tous et la semaine
prochaine